وداعا يتيح لمن جاء إلى البلاد في
الدفعة الاولى 100 الف
كل نفطة معبأة العقل
اللقاح الروسي اللقاح في جميع أنحاء العالم
ليس للقوة لتوليد المناعة
لكني كنت أقرأ دراسة عن
الغزلان بخير
تم نشره من قبل روسيا اليوم
تحت جدول الفعالية
مع بعض الصور ولقطة أو آلاف
اشخاص
لشهر أبريل في المرحلة الأولى سيكون هناك 10
ملايين
هذا المشهد يمثل معركة
فاز ضد قطعة خبز والعاشر
جائحة شل العالم
أنا مطعّم
200 أي نوع من ero
فظة إهانة
السمك ومتوازن
لا أعرف لماذا تدرسين
أول مقاتل من البلاد فعلنا
اتفاق مع المنظمة
صحة عموم أمريكا
لإطلاق 300 مليون من
عضو خاطف في إنجلترا
ولم يقلوا شيئًا
في إنجلترا اختطفوا ذلك
المال ولكننا سوف نضمن كل
لقاحات لأهل الخير
الحظ لن نشكر
توسعية
الخوف من شيء يبقى